trying to rank episodes with Donna's
like trying to choose a favorite child
let's be honest though we all have a
favorite child
[Applause]
[Music]
see it's okay for me to say that because
I only got one kid haha so hey folks
I've wrapped up series four as part of
the overdue Doctor Who review and that
means uh I got a rank fees so the way I
do rankings as a reminder is I count two
parters as one story which means that
even though there's 13 episodes it's
only ten stories so this does actually
get to be a top ten works out nicely
it's gonna start at the bottom I'm gonna
work my way up and coming in at number
10 for series for the doctor's daughter
yeah I've gone into why this doesn't
work and it's a litany of reasons but
here's the short version if you haven't
seen the full review that I did on it um
it is vastly too condensed for how much
stuff it's got going on is doing it
really needed to be a two-parter because
it is trying to tell the story of this
condensed haunted this condensed war
this one that happened in a really tight
timeframe it's trying to involve Martha
and give her her own entire subplot it's
trying to introduce this character of
Jenny the doctor's daughter and deal
with all the ramifications of what him
having a live daughter has on him and
it's too much for one episode and it
just doesn't balance and it is poorly
handled moving on number 9 the unicorn
of the wasp now with series four only
the actual bottom one the doctor's
daughter is one that I actively do not
like from here on out including unicorn
the wasp I actually do like these
episodes it's just a question of how
much isn't quite lining up so while I do
enjoy the unicorn of the wasp and I like
the mystery vibe to it I really love the
performance of the character of Agatha
Christie I think that's phenomenal I
like the vibe and I love how much fun
Donna's having it's terrific but there
are a couple of like wonky things with
the storytelling it's a load is a little
too self-aware in terms of how it
approaches the mystery I wish it had
treated the mystery with a little bit
more seriousness and you know and done
like a proper mystery you know where
there were the hints and clues that we
could have had that like it kind
half does it but not all the way and I
also don't like the giant wasp because
larger versions of animals we overhead
we already have on earth is a really
lazy alien design I will not stop
banging that drum number eight planet
viewed another good one I think the
thing with this one is there isn't
actually a tongue that I loved about
this episode aside from just the doctor
and Donna bantering but the thing is
it's hard for that to elevate there's
too much because almost every episode of
this series has that in spades so the
reason that this isn't lowered because I
did go back more than whether to put
univer on the wasp above this is that
there isn't at the things that aren't
great about this don't drag it down
quite as much as the things that in
unicorn or the wasps don't work for me
so like there are some things here that
don't work for me the the resolution
with what happens to the head of the
company being transformed into who'd
like apparently I'm weird for not buying
that a lot of people called me out in
the comments I'm sorry I don't and the
security head that was a real campy
performance in a way that wasn't fun and
didn't work but other than that I like
that the ood get addressed overall
because that was very much the fact that
there is this slavery that was kind of a
dangling plot thread that had been
hanging on for two series now and that
was worth addressing and like Donna oh
Donna yeah she always helps number seven
partners in crime the reuniting of these
two characters it's fun it's it's fluff
in a lot of ways it's this one's not
trying to do anything particularly
serious or particularly deep or even
particularly clever it's just having a
bit of fun and getting these characters
back together and it works for that you
know that I've said before I'll say it
again and everyone will bag on me for
saying I don't love the pantomime bit
but other than that it's just great
seeing these two characters get reunited
and while the whole @ opposes living fad
thing is is it just kind of is a thing I
don't love it or hate it like it it
doesn't it neither hurt nor hinders
number six this one's gonna be
controversial
turn left so again to emphasize I do
like this but it you know it is the
standard butterfly butterfly effect
story one thing was changed created a
new timeline that is worse and it's
going to get worse and worse and worse
and worse so that it makes sense that
the characters have to take whatever
exchange measures they have to to put it
back the way it was it is the
quintessential butterfly effect template
and not that I'm saying doctor who has
to be super original with every idea has
a mean pretty much every idea Under the
Sun has been done somewhere at some
point previously but I think what annoys
me a bit about the butterfly effect as a
storyline is it doesn't it's not just
the initial kernel that I've seen before
it's that kind of story has a very rigid
template that this does in fact follow
pretty well why isn't it lower if that
doesn't do a lot for me well duh again
because of Donna she's great
she's phenomenal and she sells that pain
of believing you don't matter
she sells that incredibly well Plus as a
bonus we get willfulness and Wilf is
heartbreaking because when the when that
immigrant family is being trucked away
and you any coast in a wolf's face cuz
he knows exactly what is going on and
exactly what this is a portent of and it
is crushing his soul and it's all in his
face whoo yeah the the stuff that does
work in here really really works here we
go upper half top five the Sontaran
stratagem in a poisson sky this is just
fun i've actually really liked the
Sontarans as villains when they're used
well time warriors my favorite third
doctor's story i enjoy the Sontarans a
lot they're wonderfully used here the
performances for the Sontarans are all
terrific I like the way units used and I
kind of like how Martha's integrated in
with them and Donna Donna using her
ordinariness as a superpower her
knowledge of temping and how offices
work to note hey nobody's taking a sick
day like
just great and you know Donna having to
step up and take out a Sontaran back of
the neck and of course Wilf
here as well and yeah this one is just
fun this is a series that actually has
quite a lot of depth and a lot of the
episodes not all of them but a lot of
them where whether it succeeds or not
even doctor's daughter doesn't succeed
but its ideas have a lot of depth to
them but this one is probably one of the
more disposable in terms of thematically
and what it's doing it's not trying to
do much more than just be fun but that's
okay because I think it doesn't really
really well and on the surrey watch I
keep to a brick greater appreciation of
the character of Radigan I actually
think he's pretty solid as a supporting
secondary villain with the redemption
story plus I really like Ross I wish we
hadn't lost him okay number four and
this one's funny because four and three
I literally swapped as I as I'm
recording this so it shows you how close
these these last four are gonna be
number four stolen earth and journey's
end so this one well okay let me just
jump to the main thing that ending
crushes me it breaks my heart that ton
of begs him to not do what he does
and then for Wilf to see her that breaks
my heart again oh boy and there's a
wonderful triumph to all the characters
together in the TARDIS and Davros is
great and I it's nice having the Daleks
back in feeling properly threatening the
things that I like about this I love but
one of the things that's a little off in
this one is the doctor himself he's very
reactive he doesn't have a ton to do
besides just kind of react to what's
going on around him and it actually
makes him a bit
of an inert character in the story which
I think I always kind of noticed but
didn't like fully wrap my head around
until this rewatch if you want more
details you can check out the my full
review on the thing but Tennant himself
is a little off in this for a lot of it
that last 10 minutes or so though oh oh
yeah
so number three this one this shocked me
when I sat down to work on these I'm
like really this seems like a huge jump
for where I would have put it before but
yeah yeah fires a Pompeii maybe part of
it is because since Capaldi took on the
role later and there was that whole
linking of why he chose that face you
know to tell himself something to remind
himself maybe that's lent this
additional point see i'll Grantha that's
possible or maybe it just drew my
attention much better to what the
strengths of this episode are and that
is it is a vehicle for Donna's empathy a
vehicle for communicating that to the
audience and for her to instill it to
the doctor because he was just gonna fly
away he was gonna set off an event that
was gonna kill thousands of people and
just fly away until she begged him to
save somebody anybody because it doesn't
have to be a total loss it doesn't have
to be an all-or-nothing you can help a
little and if you can you should and she
reminds him of that and yeah maybe part
of it is that because the doctor then
later takes on that face to remind
himself of what Donna had to remind him
the first time so part of its my love of
Donna part of its the
the you know the is years away pay off
maybe those things are part of what's
elevating it but this one really sunk in
a lot more with me this time around than
it ever did to my memory now we're up to
the top two and these two this back and
forth back and forth and back and forth
and back and part of the back and forth
and I'm pretty sure that I have ranked
these in opposite order in previous
lists and I'm equally sure that in
future times if asked this question I
might flip them around again it depends
on the criteria because would these last
two there is one that I think is
effectively flawless and there's one
that I know some of the issues with but
I just kind of like a little bit more
and it's a question of what am I gonna
elevate to the top spot and like I said
depending on when you ask me my answer
might be completely different but for
today number two silence in the library
at four so the dead that's so weird cuz
I put this as my number one fourth
doctor story before and you know what I
might reverse this order again when I do
a top ten tenth doctor stories period
but I have my little niggles about this
again you want to know what they are you
can go to the episode but I like I'm at
my number two out of the thing I don't
want to talk about the nails I want to
like well what's good introduction of
River Song loved her as a character I
know she bugs some people but I like her
as a character I continued to like her
even later on but this introduction is
great it is efficient tells you
everything you need to know about her
very strange situation and it all flows
it makes total sense Donna in that other
reality but Ken this is a series for the
fields breaking my heart when her
children slip away from her the Vashta
Nerada great concept
the doctor being shaken by so much of
what's going on the triumph of the of
him just getting everybody out and even
though I won't like the way it gets
evokes later that similar things get a
vocal later I love that I'm the doctor
look me up moment oh this is so good
but today the day belongs to midnight at
the number one spot because this thing
as for what it is setting out to do it
might well just be perfect this creature
of this entity whatever it is is the
perfect villain for tenants doctor
specifically to come up against because
it renders his best skill his best power
his ability to talk his way through a
situation or out of a situation or stall
for time loose voice or whatever not
only does it render it useless it
actively turns it against him where the
more he's talking the stronger it gets
this is a perfectly tailored villain for
this doctor specifically and he loses
and is only saved by the hostfest
character and all these characters are
great it basically it's almost like a
mini play it's it's this little bottle
episode but these characters are also
fully formed so fully fleshed out so
perfectly played you could watch this
and every time zero in on a different
performance from a different character
and get more out of their performance
that you hadn't realized before just
because you're really zeroing in on what
they did it is so good and so tight and
so offbeat in terms of the tone in the
Bible it is legitimately unsettling it
is tense it is my number one for series
four so that's my ranking what's yours
whatever it is drop Fleming down in the
comments let's talk about it there's
other stuff down there
well - there's a link to the patreon
helps me cover my bills and is greatly
appreciated beyond that there's links to
my book and socials and blahdy blahdy
blah all that's usual stuff down there
go check it out but you also don't have
to I mean I appreciate it but I'm not
gonna tell you what to do because at the
end of the day you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]